Nó này 1 3 3 3 3 4 3
Tòa như dân thành của hành động tư phạt bị gáo nguyễn quan vinh
Xin nămu nghìn chính trâm tạm mi bà
Cơ phó đôi trường lựa cạnh rất đưa chá tuổi phạm về mặt truy công an thành phố Pichy
Tình phút thọc, mức an tùu chung tên về tụi
Mô bản chè phép chức mặt đuyến
Lên quan phụ an, 2 bị gáo nguyễn bười
Xin nămu nghìn chính trâm tạm mi chính trâm tạm mi chính
Chú phút thọc và giảng a số, Xin nămu nghìn chính trâm tạm mi bà
Chú xên là bị tên an từ hình cho 2 tự dành
Mô bản chè phép chức mặt đuyến và mô bản
Tạm chữ chè phép bố khi quân dụng
Bí gáo phạm a vang
Xin nămu nghìn chính trâm tìm mi chính
Chú xên là bị phạt bố năm tù vì hành bí linh quan đến với khi quân dụng
Theo cáo chạm, trong thời gian giữa chức phó đôi trường đựa cạnh rất đưa chá tuổi phạm về mặt truy
Mến quan vinh biết só với mấy là đối tượng tự có tình an về mặt truy
Lời dụng chức vụ của mình, khoảng tăng năm 2018
Mình hệnh cập mùi tại một quân cà phê để bàn bạc về việc dự lên một chuyên an
Mà tự dành nhà một đích lập công
Mình quan vinh chủ động cập mấy mấy tệ một quân cà phê
Bàn bạc về kiếm mua mặt truy của đối tượng khác
Lời chuyện về vỷ chi để vinh tổ chức mắt sứ
Tạm thịt tích
Đầu thống bẩy năng an y khu chăm à mấy tư
Mui gọi định đặt mua mấy an y vinh thông phiến tự dành a số
Mui quân trong thời gian cả hai cho thành an tại trẻ 3 suy hai
Thà nội
Suối động ý, yêu cầu chuyện trước mấy 1 lắm trự động
Vinh bạm bị sơ đó cũng chuyển bị tiền chuyển khoảng thời yêu cầu
Nhận tiền, suối sang là 1 mặt tự vơi giá bị mấy trự động
Măng về nhà cơ sấu, suối hệ 1 lòng hành tại thành phố Hòa Bình
Thưa trả công 2 bị trự động
Mui thông bảo kế hệ cho vinh, đồng thời vinh để xuất cấp chiến cụ tổ công tác hợp rất dự bàn tự hòa Bình
Đế hệ được phê dịch
Nếu mấy lắm tháng 7 năm hành hình khu chăm à mấy tư
Nếu năm kể rất đi sẻ dế, còn vinh và mấy đi sẻ khác
Tới nơi, vinh đổi sắc xe của tổ công tác để mấy đi một lình tới tập xuống
Hí xuất ra bà lâu triển mặt tự, cả hai dí chuyển về vỷ chi
Và bị lực lượng 1 công an bắt sửa tại vệ bà vi
Tư dữ tổng bộ tăng bật
Trong có chiến đều tra, vinh của những việc chỉ đạo 1 bán mặt tự
Chỉ khai nhận mấy lòng 1 tự
Thuy nhiên, lời hai của các vị cáo, phai hiêm của gọi cùng chiến cứ chuyển bản tin 1 mặt tự
Trời vì vinh có phai trò biết thực trông thương của mấy hành viên không phían
Tương đơn loên 1,5 kỳ lượng gà
Khám sét nơi ở của mấy mời, lực lượng trức năng còn thu dữ 2 khẩu cán thăm mấy chiến
2 xong xam, mấy mấy mấy viên nả
Cơ quan đều tra, kết lượng các vị cáo mời, dố, bán có hành viên 1 bán
Tẳng chức trẻ phép phép phép của khi quần dụ